on this episode we talk snapchat
marketing email marketing and one um up
to in making an app
you ask
this is
ask Gary B
everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk and
this is episode 122 of the askgaryvee
show
very laser-focused this Monday morning
it's that 6:00 a.m. yoga stunwin
that gets me into the right mindset
feeling very good at a tremendous
weekend it's a long form
Facebook posts on Sunday that completely
ripped the house down getting a lot of
head nods here from the team felt really
good about that
so that's intriguing I'm really enjoying
the interaction spent a ton times kids
feeling pretty good and smell football
in the air as training camps are
starting to open up very shortly that
excites me but I'm really ready India
for a very very very very laser foot
ezarik game boys cool but if laser tag
was on the table that would make much
more sense for this laser e monday focus
that i'm bringing - episode 1 - - of the
askgaryvee show
so india i don't know how your weekend
was but really it's nice I very much
noticed you saw my response to you
wearing that shirt I'm pumped India as a
Jets fan is a good proxy by the way yeah
we this show has not seen what did we
wait a minute we went through jet season
last year oh yeah but it was such a [ __ ]
season that didn't really impact the
show I have a bigger hopes this year so
get ready I think I think show is a hell
a lot more more momentum going into this
year so India let's get into the show
where are our t-shirts on this people
are demanding the show t-shirts I don't
see any of the designers around Andres
Cossack
coming up the elevator on the shirt
maybe the maybe they're working on this
shirt let's go
Natalie asks if you were a college
graduate today and didn't have your
family business how would you handle the
job market
Natalie thank you so much big shout-out
to everybody who was out in LA that was
a really phenomenal night for me as well
a lot of people's came out appreciate it
um well first of all I wouldn't attack
the job market because uh even at the
age of nine or ten long before I even
realized my parents had a liquor store I
kind of you know as my dad managed that
store and was buying into a business
I was already slinging as you heard in
episode 118 you know blue curtains and
alarm clocks and and clearly you've
heard the stories of lemonade in
baseball cards
there is no attacking the job market for
my DNA because I would try to start a
business especially right now I would
completely take advantage of the fact
that there's an enormous amount of dumb
money trying to become investors in
startups
meaning unlike the generation where I
became an angel investor 2009 2008 2010
11 right now every dentist every real
estate agent every trust fund maybe in
their 30s 40s 50 60 70s and 80s anybody
who had a good career on Wall Street is
now an investor looking for their Mark
Zuckerberg I would take advantage of
that I would I would network I assume if
I was in college I would ask professors
I would ask friends of family I would
just ask I think when you're at the
bottom asking is quite important and so
I would ask for at-bats try to network I
would use the incredible tool that is
known as Twitter and I would be replying
to people that I aspire to get in touch
with I don't you know 20 to me to see
the people that give up after asking to
meet with me for a few minutes after 3
or 4 knows and I know that I'm inducing
now a ton of Twitter chatter to meet
with me and I hope you saw the video I
made myself the advice I've given myself
you rock him a two-second clip and so I
need to get my [ __ ] together so I
apologize I'm letting you down but the
truth is I need to heed to this advice
I'm giving myself you know so I won't
see you but I would have saw you 6
months ago and Cuban or Jack Welsh or
Zuck's or Elon Musk or you just never
know when they'll actually sit down with
you and then there's a million people
that maybe you don't know who've been
successful who've got leverage who got
money and so I would attack the reality
the market play
the reality the marketplace right this
second is tons of cash looking for young
people with ideas I think it's a broken
bubble I think that gets exposed
I think 99% of people are not going to
deliver on that investment I think I'd
be one of the 1% that would deliver on
that investment so I'd be looking for
while in college and like I did in
college instead of looking to hook up
and do keg stands I'd be looking for
business partners and business
opportunities I think for anybody else
that is not wired like me which i think
is a far majority of this shows audience
I would tell you this piece of advice if
you are 22 years old if you were the
amount of people that settle for the
first paying job versus living with 19
friends on the floor and eating 99-cent
meals blows my mind
in lieu of trying to get your dream job
versus what you settled for please from
22 to 24 don't settle you know go for
your dream job pound for it and if you
can't get into vaynermedia then go for
the second best or third best or fourth
best on your list please start with the
moon and go backwards the amount of you
that start at a hilltop and just settle
there is an enormous mistake because 22
to 24 is when you should live really
really humble ghetto dirt like that's
that's it that's the time you know to
settle in in the middle only lends
itself to so much upside so aspire for
as high as you possibly can and be
patient it sucks not having a job in
September when all your friends do or
your friends that were juniors a year
before going back to school and you're
like the pressures on and maybe your
parents don't like that you don't have a
job but that's exactly when you should
be buying random stuff at Goodwill and
selling it on eBay to pay your $80 worth
of rent because you have 94 roommates in
a studio that's it get dirty cuz and I
know I pause there cuz getting dirty is
the price to having what you want the
the dramatic misunderstanding that
amazing things come with a price a lot
of people talk about rich kits
I really negatively look at rich kid
says I look negatively at my kids
because they're about to be rich kids
that's just real sorry Xander and Misha
eat it um but you know what comes with
the price of being a rich kid people
completely did you've basically lost in
the game of winners you basically from
day one you were born into money you
actually aren't good you were handing it
you suck
so you've lost that's the price that
comes along with it and take it from
somebody who cried every day because dad
had a small family business and I was
petrified because I knew I had the
talent that everybody would say that
things were handed to me cried every day
with my mom on the phone I'm not coming
into the family business even though I
can help it even though I want to I
don't because then everybody's gonna say
that it was handed to me in the scheme
of things I was an idiot didn't realize
how small it was to the world but
everything's got a price everything's
got a price you're beautiful that life
is much better when you're beautiful
let's that's what we all say I agree
with that but more realistically you get
completely disrespected you get
disrespected you can't be smart you
can't be good you're just too beautiful
I'm I'm serious I'm really tired of
people thinking everybody's got it
better everybody has advantages you know
what the advantages of are being ghetto
and on welfare and being nothing and
having nothing being a home a child of a
homeless parent you know what the
advantages you're angry you've got a
ridiculous chip on your shoulder you
want to stick it to everybody all of
them use what you've got use we've got
you weren't sure somebody where right
now that's it we can move on see there's
an article it's been vacant throughout
saying that the only bullet eels or
vaguely financially successful our only
reason any little males or making any
money is because their parents were able
to pay off yeah basically yeah I mean
because the college loans are bringing
everyone down you have in this college
loan I mean college is the racket it is
the singular racket these are businesses
that are I'm just walking James or seen
you said went to colleges we gotta want
to blow up his daughter spot but like
wow you know what his line was it was
like Disneyland of course it was like
Disneyland James they made it look like
Disneyland so you buy it like the racket
the racket college loans that you can't
even declare bankruptcy to get out of
that gives you a piece of paper that
does not map to anything that's going on
in the real world
zero zero reality other than the jobs
lawyers doctor I know the cliche ship
but I'm talking business and you're not
watching this for lawyer [ __ ] so
business just does not map like if I
could spur some excitement right now is
if you're watching this and you are
collecting debt to go to college to be a
business person Quint right now send
this email to mom sorry mom
Goff I don't want you to have wrap your
self-esteem into little Johnny's life so
you can tell your friends that he goes
to Dartmouth he's gonna lose get him to
go off to a solid start here huh India
Oh video hey Gary
huge fans of your show we watch all 109
episodes so we thought it was about time
the ask you a question here it is I
co-founded ice cream social a few months
ago and we're planning to have a
livestream summit in September here's my
question without having a huge following
and brand equity how do we approach
companies to participate in our live
extreme summit thanks Gary me Gary
I like the music ah that's a tremendous
question I'm actually very easy one for
me to answer you need to sell people the
upside versus the reality selling
oftentimes is also predicated on where
you're going versus what you have to
offer now India and so what I would sell
to them is like look we're two badass
chicks we're gonna win and you're going
to be you're gonna want to be a part of
this and if you invest in us now if you
give me a thousand dollar check now
though it might only be worth 350 or it
might only be worth five hundred in your
mind I promise you that when you write
us a check for two thousand in two years
it's going to be ten thousand because
I'm going to give you an 80% discount
because you Ricky Thompson are making
the commitment and you're believing in
me that is absolutely the only way to
sell something that you don't have is to
sell something that you're about to
become period and by the way as somebody
who bets on that kind of stuff all day
long there are plenty of people that
like the idea of locking in the next
three years of sponsorship and again if
you guys bail on this you know you got
to give the money back
got to be honorable to long game but the
only way for you to get sponsors is to
sell where you're going and make
promises of financial upside for them in
the future again
hey cone maker hey people that I scratch
this is ice cream social right like I'm
not exactly sure exactly what you're
doing but like hey business that cares
about the audience this year it's going
to be smaller but we're hustling this is
who we are and they're either going to
believe you or not you know this is
something I'm talking a lot about with
people that have worked here for two or
three years of Boehner and are
complaining about stuff I'm like look if
you've worked for me for two to three
years and you don't fully blindly
believe in me then you should not work
here I've not been able to prove to you
at this point we're not getting anywhere
here because my patience is running out
and so I don't know what I just wanted
to randomly say that for anybody was
watching at vaynermedia the the point of
it is the point of it is
you neither going to oh I remember
they're either going to trust you or not
when you sell them the dream of where
you're going over the next two to three
years so sell them the green and then
execute the dream Melissa asks what
are you going to make an app and what
would it be like why not have a jab jab
jab app well so on this show I talk a
whole lot about betting on your
strengths and not focusing on your
weaknesses I I as a product leaders
don't feel like very strong on it I've
got too much going on right now I don't
want to stretch myself thin every time I
build products they're always half
pregnant if I ever build an app or a
product it will be the singular thing I
do or at least the one a a la
vaynermedia and so I'm just not
interested in building it it doesn't
like even the question it's crazy India
like even when I like started like
answering the question it doesn't feel
good like I was clearly passionate about
the things I talked about and the first
question I'm clearly not passionate
right now you can tell by my general
energy and answering this like I just
have zero interest in building an app
but I'm aware that apps are good it's
the word on the street they do well you
can build big businesses I understand
but I understand myself better than my
ambition to scratch that itch which is
actually quite low it's been higher in
the past but I think you know I mature
along the way as well and start you know
eating my own dog food and and and I
just I just don't I have an investment
in it the only reason the show exists is
I invest in infrastructure if I decide
to hire two full-time developers and
really really decide to hire two full
times developers which I can do at any
point that's not the problem it's me
giving them him and her you know the the
energy to actually architect an app
right now I just don't feel compelled to
do that at all and so and so you know
I'm actually gonna like you can see I
brought the big comma and this is what I
want to make it more valuable for a lot
of you way too many of you and obviously
this weekend I got to see a lot of
engagement and really dug into some
rabbit holes on you way too many of you
are doing one of two things incorrectly
in my opinion one you're letting the
market tell you what you should do you
should start an app you should be a guru
you should sell ebooks you should start
a company you should you should you
should usually do should you should
write number two you're actually
convincing yourself because you aspire
to be something you're not
I aspire to build the next Instagram or
snapchat that'd be really rad if
really great um it's just not in me and
so more self-awareness less less uh
pondering less listening listen to
yourself
except when yourself is bullshitting you
then counter it with stop bullshitting
me Gary alright sorry
hi Gary my name is anne-marie and I'm
wondering how small businesses can best
utilize snapchat like should they be
posting coupons or promotions or maybe
doing day-in-the-life Diaries would love
to know your answer thanks Henry
hi Gary and Marie the answer is yes all
of the above uh you need to put out
compelling content compelling content in
my opinion falls into two very distinct
categories one entertainment and
escapism two utility and value that's it
that's how I see it either you're
entertaining me because I need to escape
the reality of I can't pay rent that I
have 94 roommates because this idiot on
the internet told me to find my dream
job buying random stuff at Goodwill and
selling it on eBay to pay your 80
dollars worth of rent because you have
94 roommates in a studio that's it get
dirty or you like the recall you like
the recall see you always like the
recalls yeah call that your good um
callbacks thank you for the proper
terminology or to your utility right
like you just bring absolute value I
think I think the show works and I think
I mix both in pretty nicely but it's one
or the other and so on snapchat either
gotta do that entertain them make it
funny
don't forget the context of snapchat
skews younger you know a lot of it is
mundane silly stuff or you can bring
utility which is you gamify and say
here's a coupon or a code snippet
because it's going to disappear you play
with that utility or entertainment it's
very clear it's funny you led the
question member you know the answer I
love having you on the show but you you
know you absolutely led the answer which
is you gave the example
that will work you know what to do now
it's less about asking me and more about
doing it Amy Porterfield
I know Amy hi I'm Amy Porterfield and
I've got a question for you so in your
book the Thank You economy you talked a
lot about letting your audience decide
if they want to get to know you more
versus persuading them that they should
so when it comes to email marketing what
are some tips you have for communicating
with your audience in a way that doesn't
kill the connection because you're being
too persuasive hmm it's a good question
email marketing is a tricky one
you know I think Amy it's funny you
reference Thank You economy I think the
answer to email marketing is found in my
next book title which is Jab Jab Jab
right hook I mean think about all the
email services you are signed up to
and/or have been over the last three or
four years as so many of you start to
siphon off of being on email list so
many of those email lists are in pure
utility right the retail they're giving
you deals they're very action-oriented
nobody in that space is throwing enough
jabs we at Wine Library aren't I still
think I want to take my I'm going to use
this to take my own advice we need to
start sending at least once or twice a
month it's so hard because you're
siphoned on the drug of sales but you've
got to put out content by Mike Steve I
want you to work with Brandon right now
I want to send an email with the last
five stories we wrote on the site and I
want to send it out as just you know
with a title of like reading for you
around the wine world oh let's play with
a little bit so you know that like
instead of everyone being like here's a
deal
$49.99 Game Boy old-school you know you
need to start putting out the history of
Nintendo right so more content more
content that kind of allows people to be
less on the defense every email that
comes in it's like it's at you right
with content that has no purpose other
than to entertain or inform or bring
utilitarian value to the user you're
you're getting their guard down you're
bringing them value which opens them up
so much more for the sale and so I think
that's the way to
I really do I think and I think mixing
the two is intriguing you know I'm
curious if what Steve and I are about to
do with wine library lends itself to
more content in the mix of the sale and
I don't like blending jabs and right
hooks but I always like testings a bunch
of people ask me like Gary you know did
you read Jab Jab Jab right hook these
posts on Facebook and Instagram this
weekend don't feel native well maybe
they are I mean by results of the way
people responded to Facebook maybe
they're very native maybe native changes
because native does change and so always
testing always testing sit great ones
good show like that show up question of
the day and actually lurkers a lot of
you came out this weekend I need more of
you to define a lurker to you if you do
not know what I mean it's you're a piece
of crap you watch a show you take take
take I'm not charging you for it and
you've never commented which is the only
fuel and payback that I ask for the only
one you've just taken your just take no
one you're not a lurker you're taker
that feels even worse you're goddamn
taker so please if you're taker jump in
and leave a comment say ham enjoying the
show hey cool or maybe answering the
following question which i think is
interesting what is your favorite email
list that you're on right now
not all time right this second which
email service is providing you the most
value you keep asking questions I'll
keep answering them
good tight show